with Justice League smashing onto our
screens DC is upping the stakes with an
epic busted mall brawl featuring the
heavyweights of the comic-book lineup
but life wasn't always teamwork in
spandex for the cast of Justice League
in our universe there was a time when
flash saying opera Aquaman studied
marine biology and Batman grew up just
outside of Boston with parents Ben
Affleck Ben Affleck took his first
acting role at the age of seven and he
acted regularly from that first role all
the way through his teens
despite moving with his family often
when the athlet clan finally settled
down in Massachusetts eight-year-old Ben
Affleck became friends with an older kid
to live two blocks away in the same
neighborhood
Matt Damon who he still friends with
today you can learn about things that
are actually true like how incredibly
short Matt Damon is or the fact that
Ben's left eye twitches every time you
say the words Julie they were both
interested in acting and Ben Affleck
still credits Matt Damon and their
childhood friendship as the reason he
decided to become a real actor these
days he's obviously looking a little
older which is exactly what the new
Batman needed to be he's like he's older
and he's really tough but he's broken
down and he's on the edge of moral
bankruptcy Jason Momoa most people were
probably introduced to Jason Momoa is
called Drogo but the Hawaiian born actor
has gained acclaim for more than his
role in Game of Thrones before leading
the Dothraki Momoa traveled the galaxy
is dreadlocked Ronan Dex and Stargate
Atlantis and destroyed hordes of magical
monsters in the 2011 remake of Conan the
Barbarian and it's safe to say that he's
changed a lot over the years Momoa
originally went to school to study
marine biology an education which may
come in handy now that he's donning the
scaled armor of Aquaman plans are also
in development for a standalone Aquaman
film to be released in 2018 gal gadot
the decision to cast gal gadot as Wonder
Woman seemed to come out of left field
for a lot of people but the Israeli born
model definitely has the background to
pull off a super-powered heroine kaduk
grew up in Israel and was crowned Miss
Israel in 2004 before spending her next
two years in the Israeli Defense Forces
you were trained in the Israeli army yes
that's probably where it all began I was
a girl scout
cadet went on to star in for Fast &
Furious films then immediately
transition to the DC film you
purrs as her favorite Amazon warrior
princess she claims that when she
auditioned for Batman vs Superman she
didn't know she was trying out for
Wonder Woman all she knew was that it
was a Zack Snyder film and her first
guess was that it was an audition for a
new Catwoman judging by her standalone
films ratings gadot seems to be shaping
up to be a solid Wonder Woman for the
21st century
Ezra Miller born in Wyckoff a small town
in northern New Jersey
Ezra Miller grew up in a family that was
all about the Arts
a lot of that must have rubbed off on
the young boy who first sang onstage at
the age of six and went on to study at
the New York Metropolitan Opera in 2008
the 16 year old starred in his debut
film after school but the movie that
brought Ezra Miller into the public eye
was definitely 2011's We Need to Talk
About Kevin he since started fantastic
beasts and where to find them and it's
looking like he's got a long run as the
flash ahead of him Amy Adams Amy Adams
never wanted to be an actress as a child
she wanted to be a dancer but even that
dream wasn't entirely likely when she
was a teen she found herself working at
Hooters just to pay for a car waitress
which I can see why I would be proud of
that I'd be like I had the body people
by chance she happened to be in
Minnesota in 1999 when a casting crew
came through looking to fill parts in
the Kirsten Dunst film drop-dead
gorgeous she nailed the audition and
snagged her first film role in the
process Amy Adams first major role was
as Leonardo DiCaprio's love interests in
2002's catch me if he can directed by
Steven Spielberg
but her breakout hit didn't come until
2007 when she starred in Disney's
Enchanted since then Amy Adams has been
nominated for five Oscars won two Golden
Globes and moved well past the status of
rising star and somehow that smile
hasn't changed a bit since high school
ray Fisher born and raised in New Jersey
ray Fisher started acting early in high
school musicals but he only applied to
drama school on a bet to a surprise he
was accepted and he since worked mostly
with the Shakespeare Theatre of New
Jersey in 2013 he played Muhammad Ali in
the off-broadway show fetch clay make
man a role which finally caught the
attention of Hollywood except for his
brief cameo in Batman vs Superman
Justice League will be Rey Fisher's
first film Fisher has definitely shown
his skills on stage and hopefully will
bring that same enthused
to the role of cyborg he's already
slated to star in a standalone cyborg
film rumored to be coming out in 2020
and after Justice League there's no
doubt that the 29 year old will be
getting more movie offers than ever
henry cavill Believe It or Not Man of
Steel wasn't Henry cabals first time and
blue spandex in a red cape he was
originally cast as Superman in 2006's
Superman Returns but due to a director
change and subsequent recasting cavil
lost the role to Brandon Ralph according
to MTV cattle had gone so far into the
casting process that he'd even tried on
the Supes cape the DC Universe seemed
determined to keep cavil out when he
finally got his chance to fly with
2013's Man of Steel
now cavil has finally pushed his way
into pop culture as the modern face of
Clark Kent it must feel good after so
many near hits in addition to missing
out on Superman Returns cavil almost
became James Bond and with Stephenie
Meyers first choice for Edward and
Twilight although that was probably more
of a near miss for cattle thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]